-We're about to face off
in a brand-new game called
Don't Fear the Speaker.
Here we go.
♪♪
-♪ Don't fear the speaker ♪
-[ Snarls ]
♪ Don't fear the speaker ♪
-This is the son of our
very own Doom Box,
the Doom Boy.
Say hello, Doom Boy.
-Hi, Mr. Fallon.
-Aw!
-Doom Boy is so excited
to be on television.
-Oh, I know he seems cute,
but he does have a dark side.
[ Thunder crashes,
Doom Boy laughs ]
-Hey, like father like son.
-Here's how the game works.
On your turn, you're gonna
get one random word
and the title
of a well-known song.
Then you'll have
to get your partner
to guess that song
as quickly as possible
by only singing that one word.
For example, "tarantula,"
and the song is "Sweet Caroline"
by Neil Diamond.
It would be ♪ Ta-ran-tu-la ♪
♪ Tarantula, tar... ♪
-♪ Tarantula ♪
-You know, like that.
Okay. All right. You get it.
All right,
when you get one right,
it's the other team's turn.
But you have to be fast
because Doom Boy
and I will be following
your every move.
If it's your turn
when time runs out,
you'll lose the round,
and Doom boy
will spit up a bunch
of cassette tape on you.
He's just a baby. Okay.
Each round is worth
5,000 points.
And, remember, you can pass
if you get stuck.
Adam, you're up first.
Time starts now.
-♪ Yelp, yelp,
yelp-yelp-yelp ♪
-♪ Uptown funk you up ♪
-Yeah!
-Good job!
-♪ Troll-troll,
troll-troll-troll ♪
♪ Troll-troll,
-♪ Hot N Cold."
-Yes. Yes!
-Nice!
-♪ Squidward, squidward,
squid-ward! ♪
-♪ We will, we will rock you ♪
-Yes!
-Yes! Yes, we could.
-♪ Buzz, buzz, buzz, buzz, buzz,
buzz-b-b-buzz-da-buzz ♪
♪ Buzza-buzz-buzz-buzz-buzz,
buzza-buzz-buzz-buzz ♪ ♪
♪ Buuuuzz b-b-buzz-buzz,
b-buzz-buzz ♪
♪ Buzz, buzz, b-b-b-b-buzz... ♪
-♪ 'Cause I ain't no
hollaback girl ♪
-Yeah! Yes!
-♪ Ain't no hollaback girl ♪
Okay.
-♪ Beanbag, beanbag, oh! ♪
♪ Beanbag, b-beanbag, bean ♪
-♪ Like a virgin ♪
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Squirrel, squirrel,
squirrel-squirrel ♪
-♪ A whole new world ♪
-Whoa! That sounded beautiful.
-♪ Jello, Jello ♪
Jello-Jello-Jello
-♪ How will I know? ♪
-Yes!
-Whoa!
-♪ Batman, a Batman-man ♪
♪ Batman ♪
-I feel sick.
-♪ I'm walking on sunshine ♪
-Okay, you got that one.
Oh, my gosh, hurry up! Oh, no!
-♪ Whoopsie, whoopsie,
whoopsie ♪
-Oh! Unfortunately, I'm sorry.
It landed on you guys.
-That's my boy.
-That means that --
You look fantastic.
That means that's 5,000 points
for you.
-Every time!
-All right. Time for round two.
Everyone switch places.
Chloe and Simu,
you will be singing.
Simu, you're gonna start us off
in three, two, one,
Go.
-♪ Sla-ay, slay, slay-slay ♪
♪ Slay-slay ♪
-♪ I want it that way ♪
-Yes!
-Good job!
-♪ Swag, swag-swag-swag-swag ♪
♪ Swag-swag-swag, swag,
swag-swag-swag-swag-swag-swag ♪
♪ Swag-swag-swag ♪
-♪ Call me maybe ♪
-Got it.
-♪ Crouton, cro-o-outon ♪
♪ Crou-o ♪
-♪ Up high ♪
"Somewhere Over the Rainbow."
-Oh! Great. Beautiful.
Beautiful.
-♪ Armpit-armpit-armpit ♪
♪ Armpit-armpit-armpit,
armpit-armpit-armpit ♪
♪ Armpit-armpit, armpit-armpit,
a-armpit-armpit ♪
♪ Armpit, armpit ♪
♪ Armpit-armpit ♪
-Oh, "Hey, Soul Sister."
-Yes.
-Yes!
-♪ Pickle, pickle, pickle,
pickl-l-le ♪
-"Jolene."
-Yeah!
-♪ Scrunchie, scrunchie,
scrunchie, scrunchie ♪
♪ Scrunchie-scrunchie,
scrunchie ♪
-Oh, "Paparazzi."
-Yes!
-♪ Pizza, pizza-pi ♪
♪ Pizza-pizza-pizza,
pizza-pizza ♪
-I feel sick.
-♪ Pizza, pizza, pizza ♪
-Hurry up!
-♪ Pizza, pizza, pizza,
pizza ♪
-♪ Pizza, pizza ♪
-♪ On the radio, stereo ♪
-Ah! [ Laughs ]
-That's a tough one.
I want the other song.
-What was it?
-Unfortunately, that was
the song they didn't get.
[ Laughter ]
-What a close game!
-It's a tie.
It is time for the final round.
To make things a little harder,
now you can't use any words.
You're gonna have to use
a special mystery sound.
Doom Boy,
what is tonight's mystery sound?
-Cats and dogs.
-Oh!
-All right, now you have to
sing the melody
using only cat or dog noises.
For this round, each team
gets to decide who will sing
and who will guess.
-I'll guess.
-Okay.
-Okay. Go, go, go.
-All right, here we go.
Adam, you're gonna start us off.
Take it away.
-♪ Ruff-ruff,
ruff-ruff-ruff-ruff ♪
-♪ Hey now, you're a rockstar ♪
[ Sings gibberish ]
That's it.
-Yeah, that's it.
Yeah, that was it. She said it.
-♪ Ruff-ruff-ruff-ruff-ruff ♪
-♪ Hey, now ♪
♪ You're a rockstar ♪
-Oh, no.
-"All Star." [bleep]
-That's good!
[ Laughter ]
-Unbelievable.
-♪ Meow-meow-meow ♪
♪ Meow, meow-meow-meow-meow ♪
♪ Meow, meow-meow-meow-meow,
meow ♪
-♪ 17 ♪
-Yes.
-"Thinking Out Loud."
Thinking.
-It's a different title.
It is?
[ Laughter ]
-I feel sick.
-What's it called?
[ Laughter ]
-All right...
-Hurry up!
-"We Found Love
Right Where We Are ♪
-Ah...
-"Thinking Out Loud."
-Oh!
-"Shape of You. No.
No, it's not!
-It's a different song,
I think, that you were singing.
But it's okay.
It's all right,
you did get that song.
Just the wrong song.
[ Laughs ]
Guys, great singing, everyone.